this week 220 high school seniors in
Paradise California received their
diplomas it was the first time the class
of 2019 was reunited since a massive and
deadly wild fire damaged their school
and destroyed the town seven months ago
students spent their final year
attending classes in a nearby town or
online earning a college degree can
often be one of life's most important
accomplishments and maybe even more so
for young people from difficult
backgrounds we met up with one young
woman who made the journey from
homelessness to the heights of academia
a scenic Kappa Battaglia found the value
of home they said in a New York City
Police Department Precinct that five
there's such a community with the
auxiliary officers they're all there for
you you who may have your back when you
need them the journey for the 18 year
old volunteer is far from ordinary
Athena was recruited two years ago near
a homeless shelter she's lived there
since high school with her mother
Lorraine Kappa was a dance teacher but
lost her job and their home after being
diagnosed with cancer what was the
hardest I think that first night like
when we went into the shelter system we
just had one suitcase for each of us and
it's kind of like we're totally on our
own right now like you're all just at
the will of like whatever the system
like wherever you end up despite all
that Lorraine never gave up on Athena's
promise her education I've always made
sure there were pens erasers internet
things that kids need today nowadays how
are you able to do that you'd be just
saved for the things that are important
which motivated her to be exceptional
she graduated from high school with the
perfect 4.0 GPA I was very worried I
wasn't gonna get in college and so I
applied to like 25 a call anything I
just kept applying like I have to get it
at least one and she did I just saw all
the confetti nose like wait wait I was
just like yes I like it happened it just
felt so good cuz like I finally did
something like no it's like
really noticeable and like it was good
Athena earned a full ride to Harvard
University I'm actually here it's it's
pretty it's really surreal in a way she
just finished her first year and is
studying to become a neuroscientist the
battle number truly feels over do you
feel as though you had to make it yeah
like I didn't feel like there was an
option of like failing because because I
had my mom was depending on it you sound
like you were trying to be the rock for
your mom I we were kind of each other's
rock I'd say yeah because it was kind of
like hard on both of us and so I wanted
to like make sure that she was so
smiling she is smiling and while they
continue to live in the shelter they're
looking ahead
so I came from somewhere that's a bit
more difficult I'm not leaving it behind
us and forgetting about it but taking
that as a learning experience showing
that in every one of us there's more
than meets the eye
Oh II know I can't say enough about her
she is just moving and shaking in her
new setting she loves the whole notion
of learning she wants to go back to
summer school and then next year is like
it just does not stop and and the police
her police work really is near and dear
to her heart she is such a trooper in
her precinct and and the other officers
there so appreciate her and just are
astounded by what she's been able to do
that they're still in the shelter I mean
it's an that is reality yeah yeah and
thank God they have a place where they
can be that safe like that which doesn't
happen it's lovely to see what she and
her mom have done for each other
Michelle what an amazing story yeah